okay so we are picking up with sebastian
shaw getting us just desserts okay so in
the aftermath of the previous video
right like like kitty pride has
basically been returned and and all that
kind of good stuff and so what this does
is it initially picks up with bishop
right with the idea of him grabbing that
little vine that was on kitty pry's legs
and he actually calls a private meeting
with storm right now the whole
conversation here is really him just
kind of saying look i found this vine as
far as i'm aware there's only one place
this vine grows and that's when when
storms like yes it grows here on kakawa
near a sleepy knoll within the walking
distance of hellfire bay she says they
grow as fast as quicksilver and so
that's when literally just bishop asked
the question outright i should have
known you already knew so what because
he's on the quad council the black keem
just gets away with it and the response
of storm is no so at this point
everybody basically knows that sebastian
shaw is behind it now how it is that
bishop picked up on that is not in the
same way that emma frost did but at the
end of the day all roads lead to the
same place and so what you end up
getting here is basically kitty pride in
emma showing up on the doorstep of
sebastian shaw while he's drinking a
glass of his whiskey now here's the
thing sebastian sean his whiskey man
everybody's got a vice right everybody
has that one thing that either they're
really good at or they really love or
something like that with sebastian shaw
it's whiskey right this guy is all about
his whiskey so much so that in fact
there's whiskey made in krakowa that you
cannot get anywhere else and it was only
brewed once for sebastian shaw so
it doesn't exist anymore it's like in
this one bottle and that's all there is
to it now of course you hear this great
big huge knock on the door right it says
boom boom boom and then he gets up
finally answers it and then just like
bio
he gets the old one too from kitty pride
right and so from that point it's just
it's it's it's it's just crushing man
it's it's just this guy gets wrecked
like literally kitty pride comes walking
in with with emma frost and his first
thought is like you've blundered the
like the whole beginning of this
negotiation like do you not recall my
mutant gift i master kinetic energy now
that is true the power of sebastian shaw
is that literally whatever doesn't kill
him makes him stronger so say for
example the juggernaut were to run up on
sebastian shaw and punch him and by some
miracle didn't punch a hole through him
he would absorb all that energy into
himself and turn it into kinetic energy
if he was blasted by cyclops's optic
beams he would absorb that and turn it
into physical strength every kind of
energy that he can possibly absorb gets
turned into a physical strength the more
he absorbs the stronger he gets but that
doesn't matter because remember emma
frost has the gun that neutralizes
mutant powers and fires at a sebastian
shaw and shuts down his powers after
that kitty pry just starts going in
right just starts beating the crap out
of this guy now following that he's just
he's totally flabbergasted by the fact
that his powers are gone and then
literally kitty pride's like nice
collection man this this whiskey you
have like this is a nice collection
right and he's like no dear god no right
and he's like that's a bottle of port
ellen bottle to celebrate the queen's
visit to the distillery in 1980 it's
priceless and like kitty pry's like you
know i i've been working on an
impression she drinks drinks a little
bit of it and then sprays it into the
fire right and says like she's lockheed
something goofy and then throws the
whole bottle into the fire and just
starts trashing his whiskey collection
right it's torture for this guy starts
destroying all his stuff like literally
some of these whiskeys are just
absolutely priceless right and so
following that he's like fine he's like
i don't need my powers to take you out
right and then she'd literally just bam
incapacitate them in one shot and then
from there emma frost is like okay so
you betrayed a member of the quiet
council in krakowa for your own ends you
sold her out to the verendi in order to
put your son in her place you you
literally traded cocoon medicines to the
virindi who in turn were going to poison
those medicines and then release them
back to us albeit secretly and try to
kill us from within it was a pathetic
plan but it was a plan that you helped
to orchestrate nonetheless and so she's
like you have an option here there's two
things we can do your treacheries will
be revealed to the quiet council we'll
deliberate your fate for less time than
we discuss our meal orders from the
saucier then you'll be exiled beside
sabertooth for all eternity or you may
wish to make amends to myself and the
kitty pride and make your transgressions
a private hellfire matter that the quiet
council doesn't really need to know
about so which one is it do you want it
to be a public adjudication or a private
matter and then immediately he bails
he's like i choose neither and just runs
right tries to get out of there as fast
as he can and so emma sends kitty pride
after him he goes diving out of a window
lands on the ground smashes in front of
blob right one of the new mutants and
he's like blob's like char are you okay
and then kitty pride comes out she's
like hey glob uh you saw nothing and you
heard nothing and drags his ass back
into the building
which the world would go around a great
deal faster if everybody just minded
their own business and that's what glob
does because glob has his own business
to mind he doesn't need to mind kitty
pride's business so he goes back and
minds his own business which is a genius
idea more people should do that and so
following that they literally throw him
back into the place and there's no
getting away from it now at this point
it's just like it's literally him
bargaining right like it's just the five
woods or the five stages of death or
whatever it is like acceptance and all
that kind of stuff denial so on and so
forth like he's at the bargaining stage
now right he's like you guys should
thank me right and the question is like
why in the world would would you would
we thank you here and the response he
gives is actually kind of an intriguing
one right he says like now you know
you're a real mutant we didn't know that
before and that's an accurate statement
remember when curcuma first came into
existence and the only way in or out of
the nation by any real memes was using
the krakowin gates that kittypride
couldn't pass through them and so the
initial indication was that she was not
a mutant now marvel actually played on
that for a little while and even now to
a degree we still don't know exactly why
that's the case but the idea is that he
says like you know you're a mutant now
right like i freed you right i'm i've
made you better than you were before
right he says apocalypse may be gone but
his philosophies remain right because
again this takes place after the ten of
swords event and he says i hope you
understand why i did what i did and i
humbly ask you to forgive me right and
so that's when kitty pride says okay
hold that thought just one second dude
because i'm not the only one that wanted
to see this remember storm was a mentor
for kitty pride and in fact she was
really more of a mother figure than
anything else a lot of you guys may be
too young to remember those stories but
back in the early chris claremont days
when kitty pride was first brought onto
the x-men team she was young what was
she something like 15 years old like 14
or 15 years old when she was brought on
to the x-men or introduced to the x-men
she was basically kind of like a like
the the cheerleader to a degree she
didn't go on like the super dangerous
missions but she was kind of like the
audience stand-in it was sort of chris
claremont's way of bringing in a really
young member of the team and then having
them grow up with the team kind of
adding that sort of dynamic but storm
took kitty pride under her wing and
basically taught her everything she
needed to know on how to become a woman
so she's very much like a mother to
kitty pride and so sebastian shaw
basically killed the daughter of storm
and she's pissed she's like i wanted to
witness this right the revenge here this
is to be had by kitty pride it's not my
place to to take revenge in her name
she's getting it on her own big time but
lockheed's also kind of pissed so
lockheed literally the pet dragon of of
of kitty pride rips out the eye of
sebastian shaw and spits it in the fire
and then in turn the response of kitty
pride is all right all right look you
know let's let's let's call it a day i
propose a toast right here's some
medicine for you it'll it'll it'll make
you feel better you know and then shaw
says very well i know we had our
debaucherous times at hellfire but don't
you think my punishment was a tad
excessive and the response of emma frost
is sebastian the black bishop will now
serve the countries that recognize our
sovereignty the red queen will now
service the black market and the dragon
taking your eye is not your punishment
and that's when he's like what so
basically he's lost his role in the
quiet council that previously belonged
to him dealing with the black market
that was his thing now they can't trust
him with it right so that goes to to
kitty pride and then basically like
kitty pry tells him like what you just
drank was laced with the virindi poison
that they were going to release on the
rest of us if you die right and then
storm chimes in and says if you die you
go to resurrection protocols and i'll
make sure you stay there for a very very
long time and then emma frost says
krakow will see my sister cordelia
restored before you return to us right
because her sister was just a really
really terrible person and that's never
going to happen and then he's told
should you survive the poison you will
live within your broken body until such
time that aurora catherine and i agree
that you be healed or put through
resurrection and then in turn kitty
pride gives them an eye patch now emma
frost is like you carry an eye patch
around yeah man because she's trying to
be a pirate dude like let her do her
thing i mean if i were her i'd probably
do the same thing i'd be like i might
need it at some point in time if for no
other reason than to just look really
menacing right because let's be honest
man kitty pride as a pirate is amazing
and if she had the eye patch it would
look even better
so i really hope that jerry dugan does
that right i really hope he gives her an
eye patch and so following that they all
basically end up meeting at the quiet
council the next day and they've
literally got sebastian shaw just in
this wheelchair right one of professor
x's old wheelchairs and as soon as he
gets there like magneto's like shouldn't
we all talk about what's happened to
sebastian shaw cause one he looks like
death warmed over and two the dude's
wheelchair confined what happened man
you were fine yesterday right is there
some kind of illness or some kind of a
plague and kitty pry's like nope unless
you want to put it to a vote and the
magneto says yes right so xavier says
yes magneto says yes sinister says yes
but only because he just wants to find
out what happened to sebastian shaw
exodus says yes because he just kind of
follows the hurt mystique's like nah man
screw that guy i don't give a damn what
happened to him storm of course says no
nightcrawler is like i'm a man of god
right you know yada yada yada do good
thing so he's like yeah i feel like we
should know emma says no and then shaw
says no and kitty pride says no so it's
like we're deadlocked but then in turn
sebastian shaw chimes in and says what
happened to me is irrelevant right it
doesn't really matter right so obviously
the desire is there to keep this quiet
so the quiet council doesn't know what's
going on because at the end of the day
the guy does not want to spend the rest
of eternity in the hole locked up next
to sabretooth and probably turned into
like saber to like you know you know you
know what'll happen you don't need me to
say it but he says like my resolve is as
strong as it ever was right so i am
every ounce the member of the cry
council that i've always been but at the
end of the day a message was sent
sebastian shaw is fully aware of his
place in the bigger picture the funny
thing about this is sebastian shaw is
nothing if not stubborn and if anything
he didn't learn a thing with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching again
we'll continue our coverage next week or
i'm sorry tomorrow and i will catch you
all later
peace